una visita simbólica a días del
aniversario del inicio de la invasión de
Rusia Ucrania guangí el diplomático de
mayor Rango chino se reunió con la plana
mayor rusa incluido a un encuentro con
el presidente Vladimir Putin
las relaciones ruso chinas están
desarrollando tal como lo planeamos en
años anteriores todo avanza se
desarrolla y estamos alcanzando nuevas
fronteras
Putin dijo que espera recibir pronto a
su homólogo chillimpín mientras que
wangie destacó las buenas relaciones
entre ambos países las cuales no suponen
un ataque para ningún tercer país
la situación internacional actual es
ciertamente sombría y compleja pero las
relaciones entre China y Rusia han
resistido a la prueba de la situación
internacional y se ha mantenido maduras
tenaces y estables aunque la crisis y el
caos a menudo aparecen frente a nosotros
hay oportunidades en las crisis y las
crisis se pueden volver oportunidades
además de Putin wangie también se reunió
con su homólogo en la diplomacia sergei
labrov y el martes con el secretario del
Consejo de Seguridad de Rusia Nicolás y
patriche día en el que china publicó su
documento conceptual de iniciativa de
seguridad global del año 2022 pero
desconocido hasta ahora incluye 20
prioridades y esta conclusión china está
lista para trabajar con todos los países
y pueblos que aman la paz y aspiran a la
felicidad para abordar todo tipo de
desafíos de seguridad tradicionales y no
tradicionales proteger la paz y la
tranquilidad de la tierra y crear juntos
un futuro mejor para la humanidad La
creciente relación entre China y Rusia
es vista por accidente como otro ejemplo
en el que la guerra podría extenderse a
un nuevo terreno peligroso sin embargo
Beijing es consciente de la dependencia
económica que aún mantiene con los
países occidentales